when we got together
my mind shifted again we are the story
we tell ourselves i wanted
didn't want to just date i waited
you know and i don't wait i'm the guy
who got laid every freaking week every
i was a [ __ ] and i'm just going to say
it and
it drove me womanizer playboy yes all
the only more for all the all the uh
the uh what is it now cancel now yeah
personally
were you aware of this like that he had
a lot of women
i figured it took him that many women to
be able to handle me
say oh can i damp you up right there
was that a turn on or turn off that he's
been very open that he has been with
that many i have five older brothers and
i generally he he says i'm kind of like
in between a man and a female the way i
think yeah
five older brothers that'll do it to you
i say you were born somewhere in between
mars and venus yeah yeah
men are from mars women are from venus
she's halfway yeah and i was thinking
you know i've dated multiple people and
everything i you know i don't care all
right but so he says but i did tell him
when we started talking again um in 2019
i don't want someone i don't want an
open marriage i want someone because if
i'm going to get you know i i haven't
been married in 15 years i've had
several long-term relationships but
i was like i don't want to play games
you know i don't want to get hurt i'm
going to do this yeah otherwise i'm just
going to travel the world
you know by myself and do what i want
and she's one of those people who can do
that like they have no problem just
taking off
and
we had to work through all of that and
again i wanted
someone who was going to look out for me
and take care of me
the way
i want to be taken care of because i'm
going to go way overboard for you
it's just who i am and i want it to be
mutual i want it to be
it doesn't have to be money you know
because that's not my love you know
language mine is about looking out for
me and taking care of me acts of service
yes
[Music]